Speaker 1: Hey, this is really, really funny and
also sort of sad. One of the things we've learned
about the neo reactionary Republican
Party, some people call it Trumpism.
Some people call it MAGA. Some people don't
talk about it at all. And I envy those people,
quite frankly. One of the things we've learned
about them is they will fall for just about any
scam that's presented to them by Republicans, by
Donald Trump, by Don Jr, by Kimberly GUILFOYLE,
whoever. Right. Okay. They just they fall for
it. You say, hey, we need your money because I
got to fix up my private plane. They'll donate if
you say. I need your money because I'm going to
do audits and we're going to recount and sue
and overturn the election and they just start
hemorrhaging money. Okay. They just start sending
the money and they are that dumb. They are that
gullible. One of the things many of you have been
writing to me about recently is that you are on,
you know, Republican mailing lists or Trump
mailing list, whatever, just to kind of see what's
going on. And many of you have written to me that
you're getting hammered with fundraising requests
signed by Trump, although some of them aren't
from Trump's PAC. Some of them are from the
Republican Senate Committee or the GOP or the
RNC, whatever, and that. Sometimes they're so
frequent that it's multiple times per hour. I've
gotten screenshots of text messages from viewers
showing me that like four times in an hour they
were getting text messages signed by Donald Trump
in Trump's voice asking for money. Now, right
wing what to even call right winger Charlie Kirk.
Thinks Trumpists aren't dumb enough to fall for
the fundraising cringe. Now I have to give it to
Charlie Kirk. In this clip we're going to look at.
Kirk correctly, identifies that there's too many
fundraising messages going out. He's completely
correct about that. But the funny thing is,
he says the are people aren't dumb enough to fall
for this. No, Charlie, they are dumb enough to
fall for it. That's what we've seen. Take a look
at this. Do you get some of these emails from
Donald Trump or from the NRC? I need $20 right
now, by the way, it's not from Trump. It's from
all the consultants around him. And I just I love
Trump. I defend Trump. And I just think the people
around him that are sending these emails are
doing such a disservice to Donald Trump. Right.
I mean, it is a joke. It is a mockery. I talk to
grassroots people all the time. They say, Charlie,
why do I get all these emails? I mean, I can
show you my text messages here. It is an absolute
insult to our intelligence. This is just over a
couple of days. It's really not an insult to their
intelligence. It's tailored to their intelligence.
It's text messages. Trump Rally Alert. Have you
RSVP for Trump's rally in Wisconsin? No, I live in
Wisconsin. Arizona, actually. How about this one?
Don Jr My father just called and asked about you
friend. He's activated your seven times impact for
5 minutes, by the way. I know, Don, and I know
that this stuff is not even being run by them.
So by the way, and notice that Charlie Kirk
because he doesn't want to lose access.
Charlie Kirk knows that this is this
is just horror. It looks horrible.
But he doesn't want to lose access to Trump
and Don Jr and everybody. So he insists, like,
they're not even aware of any of this stuff. So
who is it that's doing? Who has the authority
to send stuff written in Trump and Don Jr's name?
Trump will deliver remarks at a major, major rally
this next one. These like within 5
minutes, they're sending them nonstop. Yep.
Offer attached from office of President Trump,
Mar a Lago. Okay. He's in Bedminster right now.
This is your only chance to claim the end of month
seven times impact. Trump Alert. Now President
Trump needs your support. Do you have his back?
15 minutes left. By the way, I've tried my best to
try to tell the Trump team to stop sending these
stupid emails and no one listens to me so I won't
have to do it on the show. Right. You are going
to lose your supporters if you keep on sending out
this unfiltered garbage. How about this one? Biden
and Kamala are terrified that you'll click this
link. Camila. Camila, save America. People are
not this dumb, okay? Actually, that we have to
raise as much money as we can. Then how would you
treat your voters with respect? Right. So, listen,
the only Charlie Kirk is completely correct
that this looks absolutely terrible. I mean,
it's humor, it's terror. At the number of these
pathetic emails we covered one where it's like
win lunch with Trump. And in the fine print,
it's like Trump will not be at the lunch.
It's like they were going to send Lindsey
Graham or something like that. It was
absurd. And a lot of us would say
these are insults to our intelligence.
But it seems like a lot of the people that
are that are getting the stuff really are this
dumb. That's the reality. And case in point,
you need look, only after the 2020 election,
they were fundraising every 10 minutes for
audits and legal challenges and overturn
and all this stuff. And you look down at
the fine print and it would say 50, 60,
75. I think in one case, percent of each dollar
donated could actually would actually be used
to pay off Trump's campaign debt or to generally
fund. I don't remember if at the time it was the
Save America PAC or whatever else. And I think
it's also possible that Charlie Kirk is playing
this as this isn't effective, this will alienate
voters and it is too much. And, you know, it's
an insult to people's intelligence. Charlie Kirk
runs an organization that also, to some degree,
depends on donations from many of the same people.
And it wouldn't shock me if Charlie Kirk is aware
that the pie is being sliced into so many pieces
that the donation is the turning point may also
be declining dramatically. I mean, even the
Trumpists donations, I don't know what's going
on with turning points fundraising, to be clear,
but the Trump donations go. There's Trump's PAC,
there's the RNC, there's the Republican Senate
Campaign Committee, and all these different
things, all of these MAGA people with their hands
out for the grift. And it seems like they're all
kind of getting hurt. And I would if a Republican
is complaining about another Republican.
The first thought that should occur to you is do
they have a personal interest in this? Are they
personally being hurt by what they're criticizing?
And when it comes to Charlie Kirk in Turning Point
USA. It's completely plausible that that's what's
going on. We'll have this clip on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following us there